have you look at these we've got all of
the operations almost right we've got
addition subtraction multiplication and
there's one sad operation busy daily
mission thank you very much so you can
finish this hang which is divine it's
it's a verb - Heidi decimals by whole
numbers okay now we're done lots of
division before I'm going to get rid of
these four four numbers because they
look a bit we're just standing here
randomly we've done division before
we've done what Keynesian for this I'm
gonna use short division we haven't done
that for a while but it's a lot quicker
and for most of the problems with a
counter it's pretty easy so how many
table I'm gonna do three with you okay
let's think about how to use short
division to write something like this by
the way quick question when you multiply
two doubles together we call that
product product when you divide two
things together what do we call that a
question very good so to work out this
question I'm going to write to solve
this just like you see before this
symbol is the same for long division as
short division okay so I write my number
that's going to be divided over there
whichever spacing out just a little bit
extra like that and then the number that
I'm dividing with the divisor is going
to come in here I'll lift it up okay so
so far so far so good
I'm gonna go through this just like I do
normally do with our division I think
how many four is going to one that's up
now maybe since you haven't done short
division for a while you can't remember
what happens next because I haven't used
this one I haven't used this one it
comes along for the ride I haven't used
them up okay and then I say well how
many force feed into this next time and
the answer is I could fit two of them
okay now all about a second something a
bit unusual happens because it looks
like when you used up those two fours
I've still got some numbers left over
right so what should I do next
you know put the tube next few years of
zero and put another zero on your back
if done short division with whole
numbers before but not so much with
decimals this was near to us okay now
here's the thing right pause for it
turns out of hands because I want you
all to notice something crazy and kind
of wrong just happened I don't wonder
how many of you noticed it's the past
before I wrote this plant down whatever
that's sort of it please we should do I
had this theory and then suddenly
magically ten just turned into now in my
books I don't know about you know I know
I learned man's a long time ago but I'm
pretty sure it's still the same that ten
and a hundred not the same number so
what am I missing
okay so a decimal point has to come in
here right and actually this is okay if
I wanted to I could add as many zeros as
I like you right because that just tells
me what small bits are trailing along
this ten and the answer is month so
that's okay right now I have a look
again and I see if I can finish this
thing off I've got the two and zero
twenty so how many fours are gonna go
into there have any fours into 25
but remember up on the top here right
just like I added a decimal point here
I'm gonna add disappoint yeah okay yeah
I did oh that's um that's a dead sorry
that's a dent on my whiteboard okay so
here's what I'm going to write down I've
got my 10 divided by 4 equals apparently
2.5 okay now as is true in so many parts
of mathematics if you get an answer you
should be able to check whether it's
true how can I do that four times
2.5 now we've done multiplication with
decimals for quite a while now does it
work out okay it does right cuz look you
can do the whole numbers first 4 times 2
is 8 and then you can do the decimal
part 4 times 0.5 is 2 which gives you 10
your heartbeat for thumbs up
thank you all right here we go second
example I hear the numbers I'm after yes
thank you this time
okay now what's interesting about this
question is you can do this one quite
easily two ways I'm going to show you
but okay first let's just use the method
we've already thought so this is the
number that's gonna be underneath the
division sign zero point hey by the way
did you notice why I'm adding so many
spaces like I'm sort of spreading them
out a little bit yeah these guys right
like if I wrote them the web probably
write them like say like this all my
numbers are gonna get all jammed between
so that's why you can see they're all
spread out like that and there's the six
okay let's do the division where do I
begin
what should I write first else okay so I
say how many six in zero answer zero
right so they're not there there's a
decimal point here so it better accrued
the decimal point there I keep going how
many sixes zero
how many sixes zero but haven't used all
this number right so this one comes
along for the ride make sense and now I
ask how many sixes in 1880 Oh terrific
are there any remainders okay so I can
conclude and this is equal to have look
0.003 okay now question or suggestion
yeah it's division keeping mind as
decimals involved now really really
quickly before I give you the third and
final example you remember I said you
can do this one actually two ways right
well you have a look at these numbers
right can you see that there's an 18
this 18 I meant to do it and there's a 6
and then there's like decimal points
flying around right
but 18 divided by 6 you could have done
that right from the beginning that's
just three right now what you want to
say is okay with 18 divided by 6 is 3
think carefully how much smaller is this
number then this number how many times
smaller is carefully hey do you reckon
okay thousand times for how much work
out whether it is a thousand times
smaller home or 10 times or 10,000 how
could I do it Jerry waiting okay I
actually do the division right here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna say 18 if I
divide it by 10 once I'll get one point
eight yes if I divide it by 10 again
I'll get 0.18 divided by the button one
more time I get zero point zero money so
how many times do I divide by 10 three
times three times so ten a hundred a
thousand this is a thousand times bigger
than this right so therefore if what
I've got over here is a thousand times
to be that's alright just make your
awesome like thousand times smaller does
that make sense
she's exactly what I've got over here
this is a thousand times smaller in a
three over there okay so you get
employed either of those methods last
question here go and it is the trickiest
of a lot that's why I saved it for lust
here we go
can you have a go at this one without me
holding your hand first how to shot see
what you can come up with just be
careful with it
all right all right out of the actual
disease
for you but then I want you to see what
you can make of it okay
um I see if you might heads up I'm gonna
get my answer up on the board and you
can confirm or see you something right
now and we can work out together okay so
follow along with me here is what I've
got and by the way those of you refinish
the questioner might be useful to me if
I do something like this okay I'm going
to start off just like I start off my
other divisions so I see myself how many
eighths can I fit into its r0 and then
as soon as I go to the next one I run
into a decimal point so you know now
because I've done I haven't fit in the
eights in there this to it comes along
for the ride so now I say how many 1826
and there are but three 324 this two
left over so I'm gonna write you soon
again which is a bit deja vu that's fine
I just do it again
three but now think back to this
question we did before right normally at
this point you know with whole numbers
I'd say ooh there's a remainder so I
write remainder whatever but this isn't
a home run it's a decimal I can work
further what should I do
okay I'm gonna put some more zeros okay
so if I write just one here the
remainder from the three lots of eight
in here will be write this two down and
now I ask myself okay how many eighths
are gonna fit into this 20 and the
answer is two of them by fitting into
about 2 times 8 is 16 so there's 4 I
haven't used in there so that means I
need another zero for that remain of the
hang on to you and finally I can take
power e8 in 48 and the answer is fine
and I'm finished okay